foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
we will be looking ahead at next week's
episode unfortunately the first season
of House of the Dragon is almost over
but the episodes have gotten better and
better as we head for its Grand Finale I
will be letting all of you know almost
everything that will be happening in
episode 9 of House of the Dragon if you
do not want to know what will happen in
the next episode I would highly
recommend that you run away right now do
not wait until I've already started to
discuss what happens I would go grab
some running shoes right now and flee
the scene for those of you who say you
are ride or die with me let's jump right
into the next episode because once again
it looks like we're about to be in for
one hell of a ride now there is
something else I have to let all of you
know before we start analyzing all of
the new footage as a self-proclaimed
sneaker head it takes a lot for a shoot
to impress me but this sneaker company
will change your life I'd like to thank
the sponsor of today's video vessi a few
months ago we had a trip planned to go
to New York City and unfortunately the
forecast was showing thunderstorms
nearly the entire time that we'd be
there there so I went on a hunt for a
fashionable pair of shoes that would
also be waterproof and that's when I
found vessi not only are the shoes
comfortable breathable and weatherproof
they're also affordable my vessies made
my feet feel Invincible against the New
York puddles and save my feet from wet
soggy socks they are a hundred percent
waterproof and will leave your feet
feeling dry even in the wettest of
weather no more heavy boots necessary
they are by far the most lightweight
shoes I've ever had on my feet and so
comfortable it's like walking on clouds
vessels are made from dimatex which is a
dual climate knit material that keeps
you cool in the summer and warm in the
colder weather now the best part for me
is that they're lightweight and don't
feel like they should be waterproof it's
like magic in fabric form I mean how can
a shoe be fabric lightweight comfortable
and waterproof you have to try these
shoes for yourself my vessies have seen
me through those New York City puddles
muddy hikes grass cutting and my
everyday jogs and they're still my go-to
shoe by the door I I will definitely be
buying more and you should too you won't
regret it all you have to do is go to
vesi.com Talking Thrones to check them
out yourself and use the code talking
Thrones and you can receive 25 off each
pair thanks again to vesi for sponsoring
today's video and for changing the shoe
game alright now let's look at HBO's new
official video the very first thing we
see in HBO's official new video is the
Iron Throne right before we hear Serato
save viserys is dead as you all know in
the latest episode of House of the
Dragon we saw viserys Targaryen died
during the final scene after suffering
from his illness for well over a decade
viserys has unfortunately died this will
send shock waves throughout Westeros as
everyone will begin to fight over the
iron throne and the line of succession
as viserys was dying his last words to
his wife Alison were about aegon the
Conqueror and his dream of A Song of Ice
and Fire this is something that house of
the Dragon has been setting up from the
very beginning in the earlier episodes
we saw viserys informing rhaenyra about
this dream according to Visa Paris aegon
had a dream about a threat that lies in
the north beyond the wall and as we all
know this is in regards to the night
king and the white walkers aegon knew
that one day the night king and the
white walkers would invade Westeros so
viserys was giving this information to
renera in hopes of her making sure they
would be ready for whenever that day
would arrive this is a big reason why
viserys wanted Rainier to get married
and start having Heirs of her own not
only as a way of securing the iron
throne but also as a way of stopping
this Invasion From The Far North well as
we saw in the last episode Alison
thought viserys was referring to their
own son aegon not the one who was alive
well over a hundred years ago now
Allison believes her husband's dying
wish was to sit there son aegon on the
iron throne and this is exactly what
Allison will intend to do in this next
episode we hear Alison save as saris
wish for their son aegon to be king
little does she know viserys actually
thought he was having a conversation
with his daughter ranera about the same
thing they had been discussing all
season long now that viserys is dead we
will see Alice sent in search of our son
aegon to deliver this news but aegon
will not be found in his own bed with
his own wife as you all know this isn't
anything new because in the last episode
we found out aegon had been leaving his
wife to go sleep with other women in
HBO's new video we also hear Serato say
no one can know who you are or what you
seek he says this to one of the Cargill
brothers who are members of The King's
Guard Serato has them go searching for
aegon in the back alleys of King's
Landing obviously he doesn't want the
whole city to find out what aegon has
been up to so he has them secretly
looking for him all throughout the
streets of the capital that's why we see
the Cargill brothers wearing different
outfits in this scene as a way to hide
who they really are obviously if they
were walking around in their shiny armor
it would be a big giveaway in one of
these shots we see one of them running
after aegon's drunk ass in the street
now what's interesting is we hear Lara
strong say I found out something you
should know as they show a small boy who
has the Targaryen white hair I do wonder
if this is one of aegon's sons we
already know he has been sleeping around
round and we already saw Allison giving
Moon tea to a woman in their service
this makes me think aegon might have
already had a son by some random woman
in fully bottom it's kind of funny
considering Alison has been mad at
renera for the same thing now her own
son might be out having Bastards of his
own this is something they will want to
keep on the down low they also don't
want everyone finding out viserys is
already dead normally when something
like this would happen they would ring
the bells in the city but they will not
be doing that here at least not yet
Serato will want to make sure they have
King's Landing fully under their control
before that happens he's also going to
want to make sure his allies are ready
for battle because as soon as renera
finds out her father's dead she's gonna
want that Iron Throne this is why we
also hear Serato say the door will
remain shut until we finish our business
he will want the matter of succession
handled now if any of you've read Fire
and Blood then you will know that
someone sitting on their small Council
will want rhaenyra to ascend the iron
throne but Serato doesn't want to wait
for Rainier to be there in fact he most
likely doesn't want Rainier alive we can
see sir Kristen Cole is ready to fight
for the high Towers if you look at the
man standing in front of him it looks
like that sir Harold westerling's white
facial hair he will not want to stand
aside while Serato and Alison work
behind everyone's back this must be when
sir Harold westerling leaves the service
of the kingsguard which will then leave
his spot open for sir Kristen Cole to
become the new Lord Commander as we all
know Serato has wanted aegon to ascend
the iron throne for many many episodes
now so renera living on Dragonstone when
all this happens works out in his favor
if she doesn't know her father is dead
and she doesn't know aegon is already
being crowned as the new king this gives
Serato A major advantage over his enemy
Serrato Allison aegon and everyone else
there in favor of the greens will be
more than ready before raniera even
knows what hit her this next episode is
really about to flip everything on its
head Westeros will never be the same
again now if you look at some of these
other scenes we see Serato and Allison
have several characters locked away
first we see rainey's grabbing at the
doorknob while she's most likely in
King's Landing now that vamon valerion
is dead Serato and Allison May Force
rhaenys to stand beside them while they
fight renero they will definitely want
the sea snakes Fleet on their side we
also see one of masaria's little birds
being led into what looks like the
dungeons of the red key in the last
episode we saw her giving information to
masaria as we all know she has her
little birds listening to everything all
over their castle and we also know
masaria has also given information to
Serato she's the one who informed him of
renera and Damon's relationship maybe
masaria has sold out one of her own
little birds or maybe Serato has her
locked up as a way to force information
out of masaria it will be very
interesting to see what's really
happening in the scene now if they do
really want to find aegon and flea
bottom massaria would be the one who
would have that knowledge she knows the
city better than anyone eventually aegon
will be found and we will most likely
see his coronation in this next episode
not only do we see the crown of aegon
the Conqueror but we also see it sitting
on a green pillow this will be set on
aegon's head in the dragon Peter King's
Landing and it looks like all of the
small folk from the city will be there
to watch aegon's Coronation while his
sister wife Helena stands at his side
now you must remember rhaenyra has no
idea her father is dead while all of
this is happening behind her back it
leaves her at a great disadvantage while
her enemies secure the Iron Throne as
well as many allies for themselves I
don't know about all of you but I will
definitely be looking forward to her
response once she does find out she will
have a lot of work to do if she ever
wants to get the iron throne from the
hands of her enemies we will absolutely
see the dance of the Dragons officially
begin before the season does come to an
end and I for one cannot wait get ready
my friends because fire will rain let me
know what all of you think down below
I'm very interested in hearing what you
have to say as always I want to thank
all of you for watching my video I hope
everyone has a great day I'll see you
soon in the next one bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign